I'm sure that many things will happen as
a result of the March certainly the
people who attended will go back to
their communities and work with bold and
grim determination to get their
congressman to support strong meaningful
civil rights legislation and I'm sure
the Reverend dr. Martin Luther King jr.
describes his goals for the march on
Washington in 1963 and 57 years later
there is still discrimination and
injustice in this country all you have
to do is look at the outcomes in this
hour-long special race for justice we
are taking a deeper look at racism and
inequality in America as it exists today
and again all you have to do is take a
look at the numbers african-americans
make up 38% of federal prisoners but
only 13% of the US population
African Americans have a median
household income of about 41 thousand
dollars and that is $22,000 less than
the national median and 16 0.7% of
African Americans were unemployed in
April 2 percentage points above that
month's national jobless rate there are
big discrepancies here Anthony there are
our elected leaders are also not
representative of the population Tony
just 153 African Americans have served
in the House of Representatives since
1789 and only 10 in the US Senate and of
course we've only had one black
president the numbers tell quite a story
there gentlemen outrage and protests
over the death of George Floyd in police
custody are the latest chapter of a long
struggle by black Americans the fight
for racial justice and equality embodied
by the civil rights movement spans the
entire history of our country so we
spoke with a number of civil rights
activists from different generations to
get their perspectives on what we're all
witnessing today
[Music]
we're saying the same case over and over
like we're marching for Georgia Florida
today but who we marching for tomorrow
[Music]
right now in 2020 and we're still
existing in a world and a space
especially here in America where racism
and anti blackness it's deeply rooted in
our everyday system I'm really sad for
the family of George Floyd they killed
him like a dog in the street I'm
frustrated we can't get justice I'm
emotional because I don't know what I
will tell my you know my little black
children that I'm raising about how to
go out and operate in this world
the issues we face today are present but
not permanent the bounds of the police
president permanent but they're more and
more people who realize that the system
as it's currently designed is designed
people made this up and because people
made it up we can make something better
at present we are in the midst of a
protest when I was a freshman in school
in Atlanta and dr. King was assassinated
I did take to the street violently very
violently I was seeking to do damage I
was thinking the hurt but I realize that
that was not really going to change so
when I see the young black men and women
out there I know a little bit about how
they feel holding Trayvon Martin was
murdered after that I also lived through
watching Ferguson I'm excited and
hopeful because I see people out in the
streets oh they are the grandchildren
civil rights movement and I cannot tell
you how proud I am of them because for
far too long
they voices or were not heard it brought
it back to the days that I was beat bad
by police officers on civil rights
leaders encouraged me to going law
enforcement and I turned my pain into
purpose for every movement there's
always been young people who are leading
the way and what I hope different this
time is that they actually listen to
young people I think Generation V has
had enough I'm a child of the civil
rights movement my father was shot
February 8th 1968 in the Orangeburg
Massacre this is like 1918 means 1968
you have a great pandemic you have a
country that is teetering on edge but we
have to work together to overcome and
I'm hopeful that we can have a sense of
understanding I know it carried me when
I was in the street for 400 days and say
Lewis from 2014 I know that we are
fighting full world that we believe in
but we have not yet seen I'm always
telling a story about a world that I
know is true but I've not been to we
took dr. King's dream and as a blueprint
and began to bill if you really want to
see a revolution start you don't have to
take a gun and face your staling
tomorrow high breath and the violence
won't be yours it'll be from the other
side that's the way it was in civil
rights that's the way it was before and
I think if we hole
that bottle high ground we will win
[Music]
boy I get guys I get goosebumps looking
at those images Martin Luther King had
just turned 39 when he was assassinated
you know a congressman Lewis who was
with us yesterday was 23 so I marvel at
the ages of these two of these kids
they're not kids have young adults we're
getting younger and younger congressman
Lewis and both Barack Obama have said
what gives him hope is looking at these
young faces who are marching peacefully
in the streets for change Tony yeah yeah
and you're reminded of that that phrase
the more things change the more they
stay the same racism has taken a
different form today we refer to the
system and what people mean is that the
outcomes we are in a society where white
people are flourishing and black people
are not and the question you have to ask
yourself is why and it's a question
we'll be asking throughout this hour